Between the dates of June 6th and June 9th,
citizens of all members states of the European Union
will take to the polls and cast their ballots
for who they would like to see
represent them in the European Parliament.
An Irish perspective. You might be thinking they're all Irish parties.
Do they represent these parties in the European Parliament?
Well, an actual fact,
the members of the European Parliament
that we elect from our political parties
actually sit in European specific political groups,
of which there are currently seven sitting in the European Parliament.
So to help you understand who to vote for,
I'll give you a guide to which parties sit in which political groups.
First up, Finigale is a founding member of the European People's Party.
According to his website,
the EPP is the family of the political centre right,
whose roots run deep in the history of civilization
of the European continent.
They're the most popular group with 176 MVPs post Brexit
at a Irish party's, Finigale won the most available seats
with five of the 13 available in the last European elections.
Next we have Phena Fall who sit with the RENEW Group.
RENEW
spawned at the alliance of liberals and Democrats for Europe group
which existed prior to the 2019 election.
They are the third biggest grouping in the Parliament with 108 MEPs.
Beautiful won two seats in the last year elections in 2019.
Quite the cluster.
Next with the one sitting Xinfain MVP and the European soldiers
Claire Daly and Mick Wallace's party
independence for change sit with the GUE NGL group.
In English
this party is referred to as the left in the European Parliament
and they are the smallest formal group in the European Parliament
with only 41 sitting MPs.
Party independent Luke Ming Flanagan also sits with this grouping.
Self explanatory enough, but up next
the Green Party MVP sit with the Green European Free Alliance
and they have 2 sitting. Congratulations,
now you've been informed.
This covers all the parties with sitting MVPs currently
and where they fall in the parliament. Thanks for watching!